[Music]
this remains the matter all I can handle
all right here's the bubbly was flowing
when et caught up with blackish stars
Anthony Anderson and Tracee Ellis Ross
just after their Golden Globe
nominations were announced the duo each
revealed how they share the good news
with their families including Tracy's
famous mom Diana Ross did you did you
call your mother this morning you texted
because you know how your mother is with
early morning calls to her children I
called my mom but she's on the east
coast okay okay okay you didn't wake her
up my whole family's very excited my mom
in the text said I want this for you
I want this for you I'm waiting on my
mother to respond like my children have
responded I'm waiting on my mama
they said emojis number one dad number
one all that and excited for me so yeah
I can't believe this in light of
everything that's going on in our
country and looking at the diversity
this year and the acknowledgement of a
lot of extraordinary work that's been
out there it feels wonderful to be a
part of that company diversity not just
being people of color but age and all
the different kinds of stories as for
their dates to the big show you're my
date
Anthony you always bring somebody else
y'all bring you this year
listen we'll see about that we're
winning I'm bringing you
[Music]